le touquet et berck programme
figaro la ville et 20h33 et nous sommes
en direct avec vous ce soir sur youtube
et sur la page de une du site
lefigaro.fr merci à vous d'être avec
nous on est là on se bouge je vois des
commentaires qui disent as qui vont se
bouger enfin oui on arrive en est là on
a trois minutes de retard
on est désolé mais rassurez vous
rassurez-vous nous serons à l'heure
puisque le l'atterrissage devrait
arriver à temps tristan devrait arriver
juste avant 22h dis nous tout de suite
l'horaire que ce que tout le monde
attend avant que je te présente ce soir
tristan le sol c'est 21h55 etc
interviendra après ce qu'on appelle les
sept minutes de terreur la rentrée dans
l'atmosphère de la gamme avec l'art
c'est grâce à son corps à 21h48 est un
autre point clé dans ce timing
21h38 c'est le moment la cape sion va se
séparer voyage dix minutes dans
l'atmosphère il a essayé de nous plus
d'erreurs si je étape par étape
plus de 39 55 il n'y a pas de retard
possible à capituler lancé à pleine
vitesse par vers mars
marcel accélère puisqu'elle voyager un
peu moins vite et verra rapidement plus
cheap une chance jeudi dernier voilà il
n'y a pas de décalage possible ce n'est
pas comment un lancement de fusée
je suis régulièrement et lancements de
fusées ici qui peuvent être poussés
retardé etc
la persévérance s'opposent sur mars où
se posent pas ou s'écrase devant assez
ça ces kits ces kits c'est quitte ou
double mais on veut qu'elle touchera
mars
eh bien on va le vivre
on va le vivre en direct ensemble d'ici
une petite heure maintenant et on a
lancé le live en avance afin de prendre
vos questions vos commentaires
pour pouvoir vivre cet événement
ensemble et discuté ensemble de ce qui
va se passer d'ici dix une petite heure
donc je lis vos commentaires sur le chat
n'hésitez pas à nous dire si si tout se
passe bien aussi du point de vue
technique si le son est correct pour
vous si vous avez les images on est
branché en direct sur leflux delà de la
nasa
donc on ne ratera aucune image tristan
la première question que j'ai envie de
te poser parce que c'est toi notre
spécialiste ce soir c'est qu'est ce
qu'on va faire sur mars que va faire
persévérance sur mars
alors s'il fallait résumer très
grossièrement pour dire que persévérance
nos objectifs
ces deux époux s'il ya un nom un jour de
la vie sur mars
évidemment il n'est pas interdit de
rêver on peut aussi espérer qu'ils
étaient là les traces de il ya toutes
les raisons de penser ce n'est pas
possible
en revanche marc ça a été au pis à
l'apparition de la vie
il y a plus de 3/4 d'année c'est au
liquide a coulé à la surface qui avaient
des lacs ont mal à la fois comme en
classe et elle a disparu
objectivement ça suffit qu'il y avait
bien eu de l'eau il permet non seulement
d mais quand poussette
nous on va dire c'est l'apparition et la
louvière concepteur c'est à dire de 2 de
sa part pour ça il faut garder
extrêmement précise et donc ils ont été
pris
bon développement des actions orientées
un peu objectif faire une mission
première étape sont de retour
d'échantillons en fait ce que va faire
référence qui va essayer de tromper d il
semble intéressante a répété m et essai
il s'est en fait comme le pousser dans
la temps de récupération qui pourrait
être lancé dans les années années qui
viennent parle d'un retour possible en
2031 ou en 2033
ça va être passionnant à la très
compétitive et plein de munitions 16
ambitieuse de réussir mais ça passe par
idea et persévérance
tristar me dis que le son de ton côté
coupe un petit peu pour pour certains on
va essayer de corriger tout ça certains
nous disent le son est bon d'autres
disent on n'entend rien je vais essayer
de voir de mon côté ce qui ce qui peut
se passer c'est pour ça que j'avais le
le casque le casque dans la main par le
chat parle déjà parlé déjà d'alien est
ce que c'est ça qu'on va chercher avec
cette audition très ce temps c'est des
extraterrestres oui quelque part c'est
extra terrestre en fait ces deux
manières de voir les choses ont
évidemment des échanges
si jamais il ya dans ces échantillons
dieu vienne dont on parle ceci a des
tamis de faire
chance ou pas n'est ce pas la possible
perte s'est gentiment quand ils vont
revenir ils m'ont traité comme s'il y
avait de la vie dedans on applique
curseur de l'est en fait sur terre baby
a pas eu de cette trempe c'est pas ça un
jeu très ancien témoin de se passer or
mars que j'ai un peu au pif filateurs
gardanne est il mort est assez
rapidement si j'ai un peu dans laquelle
le année donc c'est aussi quelque part
une venir on comptait le fonds est de
biasi dans le temps et comprendre
comment la vie apparue sur terre aussi
donc
alors évidemment sursis certains tickets
sont fiables appuyé mais registre on est
bien sous forme de nouvelles réflexions
de la pensée de découvrir à une forme de
vie ailleurs que sur terre
gino
tristan je te propose de faire un petit
test pour essayer d'améliorer le son
c'est de couper ta caméra sans couper la
visioconférence avec toi juste de couper
l'image pour voir si c'est un problème
de connexion de notre côté on avait pas
de problème juste avant pour faire les
tests on ne verra pas ton ton visage
mais on entendra peut-être qu'on
entendra mieux à l'heure voilà ce qui a
disparu
et maintenant dites nous dans le chat si
on reprend la discussion si vous
entendez maintenant un petit peu mieux
un petit peu mieux
tristan ans tristan il ya quelques mois
de cela il ya sept mois environ
tu avais assisté au décollage en tout
cas tu avais commencé le décollage de se
revoir comment s'était passée justement
ce décollage alors je ne suis pas le
décollage de plus qu'il ya sept mois
mais le débat s'est très bien passé de
mémoire c'était une fusée delta iv et vi
je crois mais bon il faudrait vérifier
le décollage s'est très bien passé là la
capsule a été mis sur son sa trajectoire
marciano très rapidement le voyage ces
faits sont sans encombre n'y a même pas
eu besoin de faire les dernières
manoeuvres de réajustement de
trajectoire
puis il faut savoir qu'on voyage quand
même 400 millions de kilomètres
quelque chose de ce timbre là à très
grande vitesse pour viser ensuite une
ellipse et se poser sur mars dans un
rayon de 5 6 km donc on imagine un peu
la précision qu'il faut atteindre après
il ya toute une
une procédure de corrections de
trajectoire pendant la panda traversée
qui permettent justement de
une trajectoire qui n'est pas la bonne
et du coup c'est dans bien des cas
irrécupérable dans certains cas bombe en
utilisant tout le combustible qui à bord
on arrive des fois à corriger un peu le
tir
souvent au prix de l'émission de caves
l'on atteigne ça ça sonne
j'ai l'impression que ça va mieux du
côté du centre historique effectivement
un petit problème de déconnexion d'auto
côté mais l'important c'est qu'on
entends tu es ce que tu vas me dire on
aimerais te voir bien sûr et peut-être
qu'on retrouvera un peu plus tard dans
la soirée
mais pour l'instant on nous dit sont
nickels ok nous dit audrey devant
n'hésitez pas
maintenant qu'on a réglé a priori ces
problèmes de sons à poser toutes vos
questions à tristan doit lui soumettre
soumettre vos commentaires je vais les
prendre dans le tchat
je vais je vais lui transmettre essayez
de ces de le piéger de lokeren et ainsi
vous si vous y arrivez certains y
arrivent
mais je vous assure que c'est pas
évident tristan il est il est
journaliste au service science santé et
médecine du figaro spécialiste notamment
des questions de l'espace alors certains
journalistes ce n'est pas un
astrophysicien n'y a
membre de la nasa mais quand même quand
même je vous assure il se défend tristan
qu'elle j'ai envie de te demander qu'est
ce qui a changé depuis
curiosity curiosity c'était si je me
trompe pas en 2012
ça a été le précédent record qui était
aller sur mars
ça s'était bien passé c'était même si je
ne trouve pas mieux passé que prévu
c'est-à-dire qu'il avait envoyé des
images plus longtemps encore que ce
qu'on pensait est ce qu'aujourd'hui la
technologie a évolué est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre à plus aujourd'hui de la part
de persévérance ou est-ce que c'est peu
ou prou la même histoire avec 17 fois il
va chercher les cailloux il va chercher
d'autres éléments
alors ya pas mal de manière de répondre
à cette question déjà la première
curiosity est toujours en estrie sur
mars
probablement pour l'activité loonois
avoir de l'ogcn est donc averti côté là
ensuite le persévérance c'est vraiment
le faut chaud de curtis civil construit
sur à peu près la même plateforme est à
peu près la même taille
la d1 dans la même structure avec un mât
avec tête tirée des lasers sur les
roches qui permet à distance de votre
idée de ce qui suit l'entraînement
dimanche
sauf que voilà tous les instruments sont
à bord ont été créés d améliorer la tête
sa banque il est de conception en 16 ans
le saluer a été largement amélioré il ya
maintenant cinq instruments un
microphone qui permet d'entendre le site
us et par le laser contre la roche
mais cette forte une spectromètre qui
permettent de ça pour connaître sa
position atomique de la roche les
connaître aussi bien qu'il peut y avoir
c'est cette molécule sont modulaires il
ya aussi un une caméra qui permet de
faire des images très précises qui
paieraient verrez un show à la surface
de mars
il y avait des cheveux à la surface de
mars c'est aussi un homme qui a fait 100
kg bondi à 4,4 meur squelette
après les grosses différences du
restaurant tu as toujours avec moi ouais
non jésus prévention de centimes soit on
m'a dit que nous étions plus ensemble
c'est bon on est juste une conversation
du coup on entend en temps oui c'est
assez différent ensuite il ya cette
affaire aussi des choses impatiente sa
navigation
[Musique]
v y tristan est actuellement
indisponible
laissez un message après la tonalité
lorsque vous avez terminé raccrocher ou
ap
et une expertise chômage
[Musique]
et
tristesse que tu avec nous oui ça il
faut s'allier en quatre enfants qui a
changé d'appareil pour avoir une
meilleure connexion
j'espère que maintenant on va tu entends
correctement je pense qu'on va même
pouvoir te voir et qu'on a réglé les
soucis de connexion
tristan on est en train de voir sur le
live de la nasa une animation 3d de ce
qui est censé se passer d'ici environ
une heure maintenant un peu moins d'une
heure c'est à dire l'atterrissage de du
rover personnes sur la planète rouge
vous voyez les différentes étapes sur le
live tu les vois aussi tristan et loger
plus de la tête
ceku avait bien d'accord tu n'as plus le
tu n'as plus le
le retour donc vous allez être mais mes
yeux mes oreilles exactement on va on va
continuer à prendre vos questions et vos
commentaires dites nous si pour vous
c'est également au quay du point de vue
technique un désolé pour tous ces soucis
techniques on a évidemment répéter avant
mais au moment de lancer le direx voilà
que la connexion de tristan fait des
siennes je l'avais prévenu en vrai je
l'avais prévenu il n'a pas voulu me
croire
donc moi même écouter on disait triste
en ont parlé des 17 mois de voyage de
persévérance tu nous parler de certains
instruments qui se trouve qu'ils se
trouvent sur le sur le rebond a parlé
également de curiosity qui étaient
parties en étaient arrivés pardon sur
mars en 2012 est ce que tu peux nous
nous décrire maintenant la phase
d'atterrissage ce qu'on va voir d'ici
quelques dizaines de minutes maintenant
en direct avec vous mais pour l'instant
je continue à lire mon père et à prendre
vos commentaires et vos questions alors
ce qu'on va voir ses c'est donc d'abord
à 29 dans un peu plus de 40 minutes
maintenant ça va être la séparation du
module du voyage dont qui alimente avec
des panneaux solaires etc qui alimente
un peu le
le vaisseau est qui qui participe à sa
propulsion qui lamine sa trajectoire et
qui va devoir se séparer de la capsule
d'atterrissage cas tout l'atterrissage
qui dix minutes plus tard à tout le haut
de l'atmosphère martienne qui va
commencer une cape et les traits à cette
menace fait l'atmosphère qui tient à la
fois le le mauvais goût d'être d'être là
donc la produire de l'échauffement en
même temps elle va permettre de ralentir
un peu la capsule kilomètres heure mais
du coup elle va elle va être comprimées
par la capsule donc là à chauffer pour
atteindre plus de 1300 de lausanne
suisse dont il ya un bouclier thermique
qui l'a protégé là qu'il a protégé la
cendre se croise un degré sont atteints
après une minute après le début
rentrée dans l'atmosphère cette phase de
rentrée atmosphérique donc de freinage
par l'atmosphère la double environ
quatre minutes
ces quatre mutins au terme desquels en
fait le un parachute s'est déployé
puisque la sonde commence à être pas mal
elle doit être à 11 km environ je crois
que du sol même si on est encore à plus
de 1500 km heure c'est la vitesse d'une
balle de pistolet et l'atmosphère sur
mars est très ténue elle fait moins d'un
centième de celle de la terre et donc du
coup c'est pas du tout suffisant pour
arrêter là pour arrêter le la capsule du
coup il ya un parachute gigantesque qui
est déployée c'est un parachute dont
l'envergure fait sylvain mètres de
diamètre ça fait après vidéo de la
surface de deux terrains de tennis
donc ces gigantesques on appelle un
parachute le supersonique
ce déploiement c'est pas quelque chose
de facile à l'europe
c'est un peu cassé les dents dessus son
parachute qui devait ralentir exomars et
du cou et a dû reporter sa mission de
deux ans le temps justement de se faire
aider par des gens de la nasa du jpl
cercle jpl donc le jet propulsion de la
motor authority qia conçu cette mission
c'est un peu les grands spécialistes
ceux qui ont posé tous les rovers
martiens donc c'est quelque chose qui
qui s'affairent c'est une procédure
assez compliqué donc le parachute est
déployée la sandf il encore très vite
une fois que le parachute s'est déployé
au bout de 2 quelques minutes encore le
bouclier thermique qui est lâché donc là
du coup la sonde va entre guinéens le
rover va voir le sol avec son radar la
descente sous parachute dure 2 minutes
environ
la has et de manière assez assez
novatrice en fait l'ordinateur de bord
d'une persévérance analysé sol et
trouver lui-même l'endroit le plus
propice pour se poser donc faudra pas
trop pentu et pas trop de cailloux à 30
secondes
tristan depas ensuite le le rover qui
attaché avec un sky craignent pas de jet
pack sur son dos et donc se détache de
la capsule et du parachute et l'allée
rétrofusées s'allument pour continuer à
le ralentir il fait encore à 300 km
heure vers le sol ou qu'il faut
absolument le le ralentir encore les
rétrofusées s'allument pour arriver
jusqu'à une vingtaine de mètres du sol
là il n'avance qu'à sinon sinon plus il
ya quelques kilomètres heure il se
rapprocha puis à quelques mètres du sol
c'est quasiment cette plate forme
quasiment stable il ya des films qui
vont se déployer se dérouler pour poser
le rover ou sol cette dernière phase
prend encore une minute et donc le rover
est posé au sol là les filins se détache
et donc cette espèce de jetpack qui
restait à 20 mètres du sol environ comme
un comme un drôle si vous voulez sauf
que ça va être refusée méditer un peu la
même va ensuite être injecté pour aller
c'est qu'ils se crasher distances de
sécurité quelques centaines de mètres
plus loin pour éviter d'abîmer le rover
ça quand même un revers gt2 1 4 milliard
de dollars
ça serait dommage de delaby nez en sang
tomber dessus
l'instrument qui le service à ceux
causés donc là il devrait détenir 55
alors toutes les tout les temps que je
vous ai donné une leur enquête à
laquelle on reçoit le signal qui nous
dit que cette étape ça s'est bien passé
en réalité tout se passe avec un
décalage de 11 minutes et 20 secondes
parce que marc se situe actuellement à
plus de 200 millions de km de la terre
donc à la vitesse de la lumière ça prend
11 minutes comme si nous parviennent
donc de manière assez philosophique
quelque part quand recevra le hac eux
que le rover est entré
dans l'atmosphère en fait il sera déjà
opposé la surface ou crash à la surface
il faudra nous qu'on attend de 7 minutes
pour avoir chacun des signaux qui va
nous dire que l'hésitation bien passé
c'est la nasa a commenté en direct pour
dire est-ce que voilà le l'entrée se
fait correctement à ce que le parachute
c'est bien déployer le bouclier
thermique a été enlevée acquisition du
seul radar ensuite analyse du terrain
capsule éjecté être refusée enclenché
descente immobilisations sky crâne qui
entre eux qui entre en service puis
enfin le touchdown et ensuite on
attendra dans les têtes pas les minutes
qui suivent mais dans l'heure qui suit
je pense là une image en fait vous
verrez le une route du rogers sur le sol
martien avec avec un horizon derrière
est justement là que une question à ce
sujet de insolite qui nous dit qu'est ce
qu'on va voir
enfin quoi est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre
comme comme image est ce qu'on va voir
des images en direct non direct aura pas
d'image alors on aura pas d'image au fur
et à mesure en direct on aura simplement
des confirmations en dépit des scandales
des signaux de télémétrie voulez vous
pouvez parlement les voir aussi sur sur
twitter il ya certains passionnés
en fait voilà vous expliquer un peu
comment ça marche
et voilà donc on va on va suivre tout ça
est en revanche il ya des images qui
vont être prises qui nous première aussi
toute la descente qui permettra de
constituer en un film de la descente et
des caméras qui sont énoncés qui sera
capsule qui vont prendre qui vont voir
le parachute se déployer il ya un
microphone qu'il a tenté de prendre le
fond en fait pendant la descente
et tout ça c'est des choses qui n'ont
jamais été n'avait jamais été fait
jusqu'à présent parce qu'on estime qu en
fait c'est pas nécessaire pour les
opérations
il n'est pas obligatoire d'avoir tous et
toutes les images les sons dont ont
besoin les opérateurs de la nasa c'est
espèce de petite bible
petit paquet d'informations qui leur
signifie que tout se déroule
correctement que la télémétrie est ok et
donc les images c'est pour la
communication et là ils en ont mis
beaucoup en tout sur le rover plus
l'éclat capsule plus le petit
hélicoptère et un jeans on pourra
peut-être parlé tout à l'heure il ya 25
caméras en tout
voilà c'est les bardé de caméras ce qui
est ce qui va être assez chouette on
aura dans les semaines qui viennent les
jours qui viennent on aura jamais eu
autant d'image de la descente la sq on
va surtout avoir cédé images vous faites
par la nasa donc qui permettent de
donner une idée de ce qui se passe mais
la sq ont ce combat ce qu'on va suivre
en direct c'est vraiment plus je sais
pas comment dire c'est l'aspect humain
en fait tous les ingénieurs qui suivent
à la nasa et c'est pour ce qu'ils ne
sont que des petits bips des petits
paquets d'informations très abscons pour
eux quand ils regardent ça c'est comme
ça si vous voyez le dans le film matrix
quand il y aller les opérateurs qui
regardent la matrice est cassée s'était
filmé en deux chiffres verts et qui voit
passer des femmes thibault des paysages
déserts de la nasa quand une loi de la
télémétrie qui voit un petit bip sur
leur sur leur écran pour eux c'est
infernal barrages sont déployés pour eux
ils parachute gigantesque déployés sur
mars et c'est donc voilà c'est aussi un
effort d'imagination deux euros ça on
peut pas le suivre on n'a pas assez de
flux de données une fois que le flux de
données qu'on a c'est mon cas une
connexion 56k
je pas si vous vous rappelez le temps
qu'il vous fallait pour télécharger une
image ou débuts d'internet mais c'est un
peu ça à l'aller donc c'est déjà un
miracle à nous transférer comme ça des
images dans l'heure qui va venir une
contagion de premières images bascou du
cians tu vas passer par un qui va passer
par un satellite un des orbiteurs autour
de mars qui vont nous envoyer l'image de
110,2 km vers la terre pour récupérer
par des grandes antennes
voilà il faut voir que toutes les images
qu'on a de mars
derrière toute cette douce travail qui
nous paraît avec nos smartphones
ça nous paraît un peu triviale mais en
fait l'iphone
nous sommes de retour avec tristan vue
qui est sortie du cadre de sa caméra
très star parce que tu peux la vente est
un petit peu voilà merci beaucoup pour
parler des virus un débat qui c'est qui
s'est lancé dans le chatt autour du du
corps d'un virus de lakovic 19 égard des
internautes qui est avec nous ce soir
qu'on salue qui nous laisse ce
commentaire nous pose cette question un
peu ironique je pense
est-ce qu'on peut ramener un virus de
mars
si l'objectif est de ramener des roches
du sable est ce que est ce que c'est
possible j'ai envie de dire ça serait
une des meilleures choses qui puisse
arriver sauf s'il est vraiment agressif
elle a ses principes de ramener alors
après c'est toujours une place de
l'évolution un peu particulière mais oui
une bactérie serait vraiment très très
content et besoin de les échantillons
pas ramené de mars vont être traités
comme s'ils contenaient la chose celle
du monde ne sera analysée dans des
laboratoire p4 de très haute sécurité
le but étant moins en vérité le protéger
de ce qui se remarque de protéger mars
ce qu'on pourrait lui mettre dedans des
buts est de savoir ce qui est dans ces
gentilles ans sur les peaux mieux avec
terrestre voilà ça tape son intérêt non
plus mais mais mais de fait pour mettre
en place des conditions extrêmement
sûres pour éviter que de contaminer ses
échantillons
on met en place des choses extrêmement
extrêmement attendant contact des
fonctions puisse contaminer nous sur le
plan philosophique ça me fait penser à
ces une nouvelle de cadix ou celle des
humains des humains qui veulent qu'ils
veulent qui en tirant émigrer vers mars
et qui en fait ne se rappelle pas qui
viennent qui viennent de la terre et
qu'ils se rendent compte finalement que
en fait il vous fait qu'ils sont en
train de tuer mars
il veut retourner vers la terre il se
rend compte en arrivant sur terre que
j'ai dit il ya des des ventes de
l'enfant qui sont dirigés vers mars
tidiane de la coi vous serez assez
amusant quelque part d'aller sur mars se
rendre compte que par exemple il ya
commis en mars et qu'en fait on a été un
jour sur mars et convient de nous en a
chassé le cominois trappe aujourd'hui
sur terre mais la question des virus et
les importantes et d'ailleurs tous qui a
envoyé sur mars et sur les plaines de
manière générale extrêmement contrôlé
totalement désinfecter pour éviter
justement toute contamination des pros
l'an rien non plus propre qu'un rover
qu'un revers spatiale tristan il est
presque 21h30 l'heure fatidique approche
on attend un atterrissage pour 21h55
environ à l'atterrissage qui durera
plusieurs minutes et dont on aura les
résultats savoir c'est un échec qu'on
réussit quelques minutes encore après il
faudra patienter un petit peu avant
d'avoir les les premières informations
tristan pour les gens qui nous ont
rejoints dans le chat et qui posent tous
cette question à quelle heure ce sera
l'atterrissage est acquis alors qu'est
ce qu'on va voir
est ce que tu peux nous rappeler ce
qu'on va vous et une grosse vingtaine de
minutes alors ça va commencer en fait à
21h38 à 21h38 y voir là la séparation du
module de brouillage et un château
s'inquiétait pas on va voir le module de
voyage qui va se séparer à 21h38 on va
le voir
la nasa va pour montrer une image de
synthèse il est temps de savoir s'il
reçoit le signal envoyé par la smo qui
dit confiant que cette séparation c'est
bien fait et ça ça intervient donc à 29
38 puis à 21h48 on devrait avoir le
signal qui montre que la capsule est en
train de rentrer dans l'atmosphère
ça c'est intérieur 48 puis de 21h40 à
21h55 c'est une phase de cette route de
terreur dans lesquels on va voir contre
sélectivement l'échauffement du bouclier
thermique une minute après un train de
bousfer puis trop longtemps encore plus
tard le déploiement du parachute depuis
deux minutes plus tard la séparation du
rover de sa de son parachute
puis ensuite la dernière minute la phase
de descente sous rétrofusées et le
skytrain donc ses fils un qui vont
déposer le broker au sol on devrait
avoir dans la salle de contrôle de la
nasa un point régulier
voilà quasiment seconde par seconde des
essais qui sont envoyées par la sonde
une petite phase dans la phase sur
bouclier thermique ou généralement les
il n'y a pas de communication possibles
parce qu'il ya toute une boule de feu
qui entoure la qui entoure la capsule et
qui en fait perturbe les communications
radio et du coup on gère les attend
cette phase là on est aveugle et sourd à
la cenc il par une ou deux minutes comme
ça on n'a aucune information
sinon il dotera d'égrainer
progressivement en fait chacune de ces
états c'est ce soir un commentaire pour
toi qui va peut-être vous surprendre ses
restes et des compétences en langue
française
pourquoi est ce qu'on parle
d'atterrissage sur mars est pas damart
si sage est ce qu'il ya une raison
scientifique ou c'est purement
grammaticales enfin une question à la
séance non c'est purement française qui
refuse le terme damart si sage bon c'est
vrai que c'est pas très heureux il ya le
fait que en français la terre la planète
et une à terre le sol en utilise un peu
le même mot c'est un peu moins le c'est
un peu moins le cas
en anglais on parle plutôt de grandes
marques simone di sole cram n'ont cessé
on sait pas très joli mais de la même
manière voilà ce qu'il faut dire
alunissage qu'il faut dire atterrissage
sur la lune où chacun se fera sa propre
opinion
personnellement je trouve le terme
damart si sa très jolie donc atterrir
atterrissage sur mars a très bien mais
je n'ai certainement fusil à quelqu'un
qui disait marc 6h ça peut paraître un
débat un débat un débat digne et je la
langue française est vivante dérange pas
qu'on puisse inventer des mots en tout
cas le figaro il a été choisi de parler
d'atterrissage si on mars et pas de
marcy sage si vous consultez
article de la rubrique science écrit
notamment mais pas que par tristan qui
étaient avec nous ce soir vous pourrez
lire atterrissage sur mars et dont amar
si sage on à cette question de
contraindre le chat qui me dit j'espère
c'est une question ou un commentaire
à la fin duquel pour pas en rajouter un
peu de regret sur les dix ans plus mars
a encore une magnétosphère pour protéger
une éventuelle vie des radiations
cosmiques point d'interrogation mars at
il cette année tous non martèle la deux
noms mars a pas de mafia justement c'est
l'objet d'une autre d'une autre mission
qu'on avait pu suivre quillan sur
l'insight avec un sismomètre français
s'est posé
maintenant je crois que c'est en 2018
pas dire de bêtises c'est 2018 qui s'est
posée qu'elle dépose ainsi se remettre à
la surface pour regarder les vibrations
du sol martien pour réfléchir de
répondre à cette question pourquoi le
coeur de mars s'est il arrêté de battre
donc qu'en dit le coeur c'est du noyau
de mars on sait qui est lui un champ
magnétique à une époque donc la protéger
des battues vent solaire particules très
énergétiques que je voudrais sa surface
et cette dynamo donc c'est ce ce noyau
liquide de métal en fusion
c'est un vrai parce que mars est tout
petit
différentes hypothèses mais en tout cas
le fait est qu'une a plus de champ
magnétique soma c'est d'ailleurs en cas
de sur martienne ça fait partie des
enjeux il faudra se protéger je vous en
laisse protéger des rayons cosmiques et
du champ solaire de ces particules
chargées parce qu'ils sont elles sont
cancérigènes elles sont mauvaises pour
la santé
donc voilà il ya des des concours de la
nasa s'est imaginé par de même pendant
le voyage de se protéger avec le look on
ramène pour la boire loup est un bon
bouclier
donc toi de mettre ses réserves tout
autour du vaisseau créer des abris
martien les enterrer
enterrés dans des sous le sol justement
faire des structures gonflables avec
laquelle on peut mettre de l'eau se
protéger de ces rayonnements c'est tout
un tout un pan de la problématique de la
conquête de mars à bichat dans le char
qui nous dit à caen 1-1 à jupiter âge et
savas pire une autre une autre question
pourquoi c'est sur mars qu'on a ce
pouvoir jeter notre dévolu pour quoi
sert cette planète qu'on se tourne
maintenant alors c'est très simple c'est
la plus près voilà c'est sais c'est pas
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça la lune
est plus proche la lune est petit voilà
pense qu'il a fallu que la jeune fille
était une atmosphère que là je n'ai pu
être propice à la vie en a visité venus
notamment les les soviétiques pour
convier de son sont venus mais on s'est
vite rendu compte que il faisait une
chaleur étouffante à sa surface
plusieurs centaines de degrés avec des
pluies acides sur une pression énorme il
nous conte pense que là on a plus de
doute sur le fait que vénus et plus être
propice un jour à la vie et du goût
actuellement il n'est pas possible de
vraiment de poser un rover sur vénus
bien trop de pression trop d'acidité
trop de chaleur donc c'est pas faire une
électronique qui survivraient dans ces
conditions que quelques secondes
donc ça rend tous ces projets le
difficile il ya eu des projets plus
ésotériques
il est arrivé qu'on pouvait revenir
peut-être dans les années qui viennent
de volée dans les nuages de vénus a
découvert un palau un dirigeable par
exemple pour faire de l'exploration
vénitienne il ya des théories un peu
plus entendu parler de vie dans les
nuages de vénus bon c'est très poétique
si c'est on va dire très hautement
hypothétique ce jour pour ne pas dire
pour ne pas dire hautement improbable
pourquoi pas
du coup le voilà sur mars pour le moment
mais on est en train se tourner vers un
légume saturne et de jupiter dont on est
en train de se dire qu'elles ont elles
ont probablement été propice à la fin
que sont pour le moins très propice à
son avis à des océans sous des croûtes
de glace encore aujourd'hui c'est est
aujourd'hui le meilleur candidat pour
trouver une vie une vie actuelle et les
missions de la nasa et de lézards
d'exploration des lunes de saturne et
jupiter est probablement le grand défi
des prochaines décennies
mais c'est beaucoup plus loin donc ça
prend beaucoup plus de temps pour y
aller donc ça coûte plus cher voilà donc
ces mots c'est pour ça qu'on a commencé
par mars
rien n'interdit de penser qu'on pourra
aller à l'ailé 21h37 et nous sommes
toujours en direct poursuivre avec vous
cet événement l'atterrissage durant leur
persévérance sur mars est maintenant
dans une vingtaine de minutes un petit
peu plus de 20 minutes maintenant six
ans en vendant de 21 55 ans continue à
prendre vos questions et vous connaissez
dans le chat en attendant avec le
traitement personne n'a réussi à coller
tristan encore pour l'instant je
continue à dérouler la question là cette
question de tom d'aqui le montre que la
température sur mars en face à face
cachée du soleil ou face au soleil alors
je vais pas dire de bêtises ont quand
même si je trouve mais la bloquant sur
moyenne distance de mars est moins 50
degrés celsius en moyenne les écarts
thermiques sont assez importants savary
grosso modo entre moins 20 et moins 200
je croise à 50 en 200 je voulais faire
ça moi après ça peut monter au maximum
leur corps ces 25 degrés ou 27 degrés
celsius
et ça c'est vraiment à l'équateur qu'en
mars il au plus proche du soleil en été
c'est en leur crachant ses besoins
sexuels
globalement la température ne décolle
jamais on va faire une annonce sur le
chat face à nice 0 1
j'ai une question pourquoi sur les
animations on voit lors de la descente
du rover du rover sur les câbles on voit
huit moteurs allumés alors qu'il y en
aura que 4 il semble que c'est ce que tu
nous a précisé par doit tout à l'heure
au début alors tu n'as pas forcément
l'animation et les yeux puisque je n'ai
pas assez d'or pendant une de tes
explications pour pour illustrer ces
dans l'animation une animation fournies
par la nasa
l'animation trailer qu'on montre duran
duran ce live on voit effectivement
qu'il ya eu beau terminer et une précisé
que quatre anneaux je peux seulement de
votre offre
ok je ne sais pas comment j'ai gagné 100
plus vite je suis tout à fait disposé à
port à croire qu'un v8 dont il ya des
rétrofusées j'veux pas grandir en a
exactement où clément il a quatre il ya
quatre filles et quatre cordes quatre
fils un qui dépose mais les lettres
officielles cette accueillir exactement
quel chat un plus d'informations que
nous
n'hésitez pas à nous le dire dans vos
commentaires
en ce moment là sébastien chat qui nous
dit les missions spatiales sont toujours
conçu de sorte à ne pas envoyer de
gerbes dans le cosmos s'attristant a
parlé tout à l'heure la désinfection du
matériel spatial
c'est fou c'est un sujet assez
intéressant parce que ça veut dire que
quand on fait ça on prend soin justement
de ne pas polluer l'espace en fait c'est
ça l'idée où ça à d'autres buts beaucoup
plus terre-à-terre
non c'est ça c'est cesser enfin c'est
pas le point de vue au centre el polluer
avec eux voilà papa ramener de la vie
ailleurs
c'est patent pour difficiel oui assez
patent en vérité c'est patent au doute
bien que si on ramène quelques bactéries
sur l'art se elles vont pas proliférer
pour coloniser mars c'est plutôt quand
je torée faire des mesures si jamais ben
une bactérie dans le dans le dans
l'échantillon qu'on est en train
d'analyser conservation et de matières
organiques
oui c'est la bactérie qu'on a amené les
matières organiques mais c'est pas ça
qui nous intéresse pour ses coûts des
matières organiques que je replace dans
un point est faussé les résultats
c'est plus dans cette idée là qu on
dépollue parce que finalement bien de
chant dans la partie spatiale à on
envoie des dérouleurs des sondes qui se
crashe façon là il ya un petit peu de il
ya un article position après échec d'une
planète c'est vraiment très minime alors
que l'on a l'habitude de voir maintenant
d'innovation fin mars une belle boule
etc
[Musique]
on a l'image on a l'impression que brad
pitt ou sur mars ça va être énorme en
fait tu mens cible à grand-chose à mars
est très grand ça fait à peu près la
moitié de la taille de la terre
donc voilà s'il y avait eu 10 voitures
qui rouillent serait-ce de la terre je
vous défie ray de ruches à les retrouver
même avec une batterie satellite serait
pas imminente
et d'ailleurs on a toujours du révérend
du mal à trouver les traces c'est pas
évident trouvé les traces d'un krach par
exemple de trouver l'autre u2 le
parachute dexter alors qu'on a dit c'est
pas toujours évident la plus chère
relative dans le moule
il est 21 heures 44 minutes fait tous
les faits on est à 6 minutes 25,2 du
début de l'entrée dans l'atmosphère près
quand vous voyez en bas à droite de
notre image le timer qui a été lancé par
la nasa
je rappelle en direct sur ces images de
la salle de contrôle dont dans six
minutes maintenant
le rover entrera donc l'atmosphère de
mars pour tous
jour de sortie nous demande quand est ce
que les images en direct
tristan est ce que tu me reçoit toujours
qu'on verra pas des images en direct
mais quand on voit des enfants très très
rapide pour savoir si oui correctement
correctement atterri à la surface de
mars
j'espère que vous pouvez me former
également que moi je suis de mon côté on
parle en effet crashé
j'espère que ma connexion en tout cas du
mode effectivement on a eu quelques
petits problèmes de son et maintenant
s'est rétabli car voilà c'est pour nous
y trente sept ans conduire à une image
réelle prise par persévérance dans la
ferme
oui je pense après je ne vais pas me
donner une heure précise mais oui
théoriquement je vais la voir dans la
soirée je pense cette image juste pas
trop lourd à votre live c'est une image
qui est prise à travers une des caméras
travers son cache donc les rangs des
petits cash pour les protéger est ce que
commande la descente ses moteurs fusées
l'arête du monde dégage la poussière la
balle rover et donc vous protège les
objectifs eux il est petit cache qui
sont ensuite enlevé enlever une fois une
fois arrivé en tête avec un resort s'il
vous plaît est donc une première image
qui vient à travers ce cachot combat
généralement suit on voit ensuite une
image un peu floue dernière c'est pas
des images
leur a ensuite mais ça donne des
informations visuelles que leurs larbins
arriver oui oui un petit peu de bruit
autour de toi juste oui c'est le châtain
voyez c'est pas la vaisselle arrêter de
faire la vaisselle à côté c'est le
chacun semble faire des siennes et qui
va assister dans un peu plus de trois
minutes maintenant à l'entrée dans
l'atmosphère est ce que tu sais triste
en commet là
la nasa va modéliser ça puisqu'on ne
verra pas les images en direct ce que tu
as une idée et je présume qu'ils vont
essayer de reconstituer de reconstituer
les petits des images de synthèse qu'ils
ont diffusé dans la soirée pour cible
les égrainer au fur et à mesure que les
étapes se reproduise
je pris donc c'est comme ça il vous pour
le moins interrogés chefs des missions
aussi aux intérêts sa démission qui
explique un peu ce qui se passe ou
commentées en tout cas il ya entendre en
audio ce que se disent les ingénieurs
qui vont se parler entre ça qui va nous
permettre je suis tombé à 3 minutes
phase élaborons we do précise il n'y
aura que quatre moteurs soit 25 degrés
d'inclinaison et non ceux à 5 degrés
pour éviter d'endommager le rover voilà
par rapport à lexie m'opposait composer
tout à leur merci beaucoup pour ces pour
ces précisions
effectivement et puis on a un gamin qui
nous dit dans le tchat qu'est ce qui
nous prouve que tout ce que vous
racontez n'est pas faux depuis depuis
tout à l'heure
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire un gamin quand
est ce qu'on peut lui prouver que tout
ce qu'on raconte n'est pas fou je pense
que la réserve de classe donc c'est une
posture qui consiste à dire que la
manière qu'il faut toujours se fier à la
manière la plus simple c'est que les
choses et en fait comment expliquer que
la nasa tous les gens qui travaillent là
bas tous les américains tous les gens
qui touchent de près ou de loin les
programmes lunaires et les programmes
actuels et ça faire rentrer toutes ces
personnes là dans un même couple
organisée
extrêmement compliqué je violente être
bien plus compliqué que de réaliser la
prouesse elle même d'envoyer quelqu'un
sur l'avenue où que voilà pour les
rovers c'est pareil
voyez il ya des échecs que ça voilà
serais je pas comme dans la réalité
dépasse souvent la fiction quand ce
serait très dur d'arriver à scénariser a
scénarisé toute la recherche spatiale
qui fait des choses bien et c'est tout
ce qu'on est capable et d'essayer les
décennies de recherches spatiales
on est à une minute de l'entrée dans
l'atmosphère du rover on voit que la
tension monte dans la salle de contrôle
ont évidemment suivre ça en direct avec
vous en attendant je prends la question
de isap curiosity petit fils mais
l'atterrissage de persévérance est-ce
que non georges et il se rapproche de
persévérance non il est beaucoup trop
loin
à ma connaissance les auditeurs qui sont
à proximité je ne crois pas qu'ils
puissent non que l'observer en revanche
la s'élance lui même à des caméras
il va réussir à prendre un certain
nombre d'image de la descente ne peut
pas les envoyer en direct en streaming
au fur et à mesure qu'on les aura et
d'envié dans les jours dans les jours
les semaines à venir
ça va être vraiment des images hyper
intéressante si vous voulez on pourra
les commenter
revenir ici les commenter quand elles
quand elles seront diffusées mais c'est
que débute donc l'entrée dans
l'atmosphère comme tu le disais tristan
c'est une animation 3d qui va nous la
faire vivre je vous propose qu'on la
suive ensemble
oui alors la triste ans c'est le site
d'atterrissage
j'ai le cratère de vision voilà on va le
4 2 0 là bas on voit la capsule qui
s'approche il utilise en fait un
logiciel de la nasa qui permet de suivre
le bas semble donc la commentatrice
égrène la vitesse à laquelle se déplace
là la seule j'ai un retour sans qui
vient de chez toi merci mandagout dixel
qui nous demandent pas d'air donc pas de
bruit sur mars qu internationaux
s'il ya de l'air je sais exactement ce
que ça donne sur le son mais il ya une
autre mosquée 1% de celle de la terre
donc je quand je danse agir comme ça
intuitivement que ça fait des sens plus
aigu mais je vous dis ça un petit peu
c'est un peu de la pro je suis je me
rappelle que exactement checa deux
microphones mba qui va te devais
enregistrer le bruit de la descente mais
encore une fois pareil le sens nous sera
téléchargée dans les jours qui viennent
pas en est ce qu'on peut pour christophe
précisé le prix ont très le coût de ce
rover persévérance il nous dit xxxx x 3
x 15 euros c'est beaucoup plus que ça on
va jouer 2 4 milliards de dollars
auxquels il faut rajouter 300 millions
pour les trois premières années
d'opération
c'est où tous les salaires des gens qui
ont fait travailler son émission c'est
une fourchette assez de 0,4 milliard
c'est ce qu'on appelle les missions
flagship de la nasa il nous tous les
cinq ans environ
c'est l'émission étendard c'est les
grosses missions les plus grosses
missions de lagence donc les plus chers
on a face au gabon qui nous demandent et
si le rover ce crash
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est vers 6 h
on va régir milliards d'euros 1 2
milliard d'euros partout de 25 milliards
jetés à la poubelle
il faudrait voir à titre personnel je
planche ça pourrait sonner le glas de
cette mission d'autres d'échantillons je
sais pas s'ils ont six ans survolant
serait dans quelle crise dans six
ambitieux si on rate déjà la première
étape mais bon ça si bref c'est tout
toutes les agences de doivent voir base
qu'est ce qu'elle peut le faire on peut
pas reconstruire
c'est en théorie on peut vous construire
un over un coin un peu plus faible mais
je pense pas que ce serait fait en
vérité je pense que le programme
voilà on essaie de comprendre ce qui
s'est passé il y aurait des enquêtes
mais y'a pas grand chose à faire un
check de ce type là est ce que tu peux
nous ré expliquer ce qu'on est en train
de voir pour les gens qui nous
rejoignent qui se demande pourquoi on ne
voit pas d'image qui se demandent ce
qu'ils sont en train de regarder ce
qu'on voit à gauche ce sont les
différentes phases si je me trompe pas
est ce que tu peux nous décrire ce qu'on
voit alors je sais pas sur quelle partie
de moi ce que je vois là c'est la leçon
qui est en train d'arriver à ces images
membres ou de la glace en qui arrive le
maintenant se faire martienne et c'est
des images d'un site d'un logiciel de la
nasa qui utilisés pour suivre la
traversée donc il ne modernise pas
d'échauffement notamment là en principe
en principe le bouclier thermique est en
train de chauffer appelé 1300 budget et
là ils sont en train de surveiller la le
ralentissement de la sonde directive la
sangle ralenti correctement contrat
comme comme prévu
alors là voilà elle dit en gros qu'on va
bientôt déployé le parachute voilà le
parachute s'est déployé donc tout le
monde applaudit donc là le parachute
s'est déployé correctement ils ont eu la
confirmation je roulais effectivement à
gauche la liste des différentes
opérations je parlais tout à l'heure
elles sont évidemment plus en détails et
donc
donc là on a 9 km 5 de la surface le
bouclier thermique ça a été a été enlevé
ce qui permet donc aux rovers sont
radars et de caméras de regarder le sol
nous le faire une cartographie du site
d'atterrissage et de regarder en fait je
surveillais l'altitude à laquelle il
descend tout la télémétrie sans le
montrer que lepage c'est bien déployer
que la sonde ralenti correctement donc
la toile applaudi parce que appris le
métier qui sont montrés que là le
changement d'altitude et confort est ce
qu'on attend le vol du para schiste fait
pas assez bien déployer un emplacement
correctement et donc elle descend à la
vitesse à laquelle en place à temps si
c'était pas déployées elles des cendres
est beaucoup trop vite
si le si le bouclier allait séparer le
radar mme saule et c'est donc là tout
tout la télémétrie en fait permettre de
s'assurer que toutes les étapes se
déroulent correctement ces indices
indirects là on peut voir on peut voir
que pour ceux qui se posent la question
dans le choc oui on est en ce moment est
donc là le mètre du sol est là la sonde
a enlevé son parachute et son bac chez
sa coquille et donc pendant ces la métro
fusée qui s'arrêtait ce qu'on peut voir
sur les images vous allez être aux
fusils sont mis en marche vous finalisez
ralentissement la semaine d'affilée
encore à 300 km parce que 300 km/heure
environ d'une auto cela ralentisse
encore élevés de l'essence jusqu'à 20
mètres du sol et elle peut exercer un un
mouvement latéral que 600 mètres pour
aller se poser à un endroit qu'elle est
voilà là on est à vingt mètres de la
surface environ et donc le sky one s'est
déployée pour en principe déposer leurs
opérations face
et voilà super et voilà vous voyez
l'explosion de joie dans le centre de
contrôle de la nasa ski super ça aussi
que c'est réussi pour persévérance
tristan pour beaucoup de ces gens là
c'est des années des années à battre
mais j'imagine mais je n'aime pas le
soulagement quoi ça doit être
alors maintenant voilà donc le ferait
sur que le rover
le rover n'a pas été endommagé que tous
vous correctement vianney plusieurs
joutes vont être passées à tous checker
mais mais mais là ça veut dire que tout
s'est déroulé correctement poésie lui
loin de votre problème mais un peu
embêté de free donc là et voilà tout
tout laisse penser que le blogueur est
en bonne santé et on attend maintenant
une image qui avait concerné qu'on est
bien la science
combien de temps est-ce qu'on va
l'attendre cette image tu sais je sais
pas du tout en fait ça va être ça dépend
en fait le blé ça dépend des satellites
lanaverre s'engage pas forcément parce
qu'en gros il ya peu de satellites en
orbite autour de mars
et ça ça demande un peu de données donc
s'ils arrivent à la transférer tout de
suite ça peut arriver très vite dans les
minutes qui suivent
s'il faut attendre le passage d'un autre
d'un autre satellite rhône est simple
prendre plus de temps si j'irai où
quelques minutes que vous alors qu'une
dizaine de minutes à quelques heures en
fonction des en fait quand il se pose
tout est fait pour qu'il y ait au moins
un ou deux relais pendant la période
décembre pourront plus sûrement suivre
cette cet atterrissage en direct on peut
savoir les de la télémétrie en direct
nous des satellites ça va très vite et
donc du coup passé un moment en fait
voilà le rover si vous le ne voit plus
le satellite est ce qu'il passe derrière
l'en et on peut plus communiquer
directement le rover plomb vouliez peut
parfois envoyer des choses vers la terre
là je crois qu'il ne peut pas
communiquer directement avec la terre
depuis son site d'atterrissage
il pouvait jusqu'à une inspirante
s'adressant avec la terre mais a envoyé
juste vraiment indique quoi c'est une
antenne kiki pas cap
d'envoyer beaucoup de données donc
savoir où ils vont passer par mary
satellite rhône est en tout cas on va
attendre avec ces premières images on a
encore du temps devant nous on va
continuer ce live en espérant les avoir
le plus le plus rapidement possible
alors que vous voyez les membres de
l'équipe qui se font prendre en photo
pour immortaliser ce moment sans doute
un des plus grands fiascos le plus
important de leur carrière ont continué
à prendre vos messages et notamment ceux
cette question de leur enclos demandent
comment et choisit le lieu
d'atterrissage tristan le lieu et il a
été choisi
depuis plusieurs années je regarde un
peu les images la salle de contrôle pour
voir si des fois sur les faces qu'il
soit aisé quand le contrôle on voit
apparaître une première image le lot 6
nations il s'agit il est choisi
plusieurs années simple sur wii
plusieurs années avant d'arriver c'est
beaucoup de scientifiques les avoirs de
jijel qui vont de choisir et là en
l'occurrence on cherchait un site qui
soit un endroit où il ya eu de l'eau
liquide assez voilà c'est l'image on la
voit donc cette bulle de tristesse qu'on
peut la décrire c'est une d une des
caméras du monde et cameyrac et sur le
rover laquelle laquelle il s'agit il ya
le cash qui est dessus donc c'est pour
ça que l'image pas très net
c'est bien qu'il ya elle est un peu
floue et ses caméras près de devenir
d'image mais ça devrait déjà avoir une à
laval à l'ombre du rover donc le soleil
est levé sur marthe assez chouette
bon bah voilà ce qui ne croit que ce
qu'il voit
voilà c'est une seule de marx et s'il
sonne tel que le voient c'est un nouvel
endroit qu'on va explorer sur mars
on a exploré qu'une dizaine d'endroits
même pas sur mars
on a pu mettre une caméra et le voir
depuis le savent à quoi ça ressemblait
donc c'est toujours un peu et mouvements
c'est une nouvelle planète d'en face est
super chouette
voilà ça y est ils nous la montre en
plein écran vous la voyez ici il y en a
même plusieurs arts tristan 2 c'est une
version dégrade lâchant voit une autre
et on n'a plus le sol
ils font le point suivant un traitement
d'image en direct ça qu'on entre l'image
évoluant face à des hommages s'appelle
une image raw et là il m'a la traite en
direct comme le ciel photoshop quoi pour
faire sortir des contrastes et c'est là
la rendre plus net
donc cette deuxième image 5 il gâche du
sol sur celle là on voit pas l'ombre du
rover il me sens qu'on voit voilà voilà
voilà moindre once le bas à droite on
voit la roue du rover très correctement
le terrain et quelques cailloux devant
pouvoir la taille de bar vous l'avez de
la route gilles la taille exacte en tête
mais c'est une excuse comme 30 40 cm de
direct
les photos ne seront pas en couleur
tristan non pas les premiers raids sur
noir et blanc ça prend moins de place
mais il ya plein de caméras couleurs
c'est une image n'aurait dans sa fesse
droite
donc c'est pour avoir des images le plus
rapide après voilà vous connais les
couleurs de mars et une passe de beige
de belges orangé et on voit bien
évidemment l'équipe qui continuent de se
féliciter ces fins des tchèques tomas
c'est tout pas se prendre dans les bras
et respectent les les distances de
sécurité
j'essaie de faire est le fils thibault
j'imagine que ça doit les démange et les
scientifiques français qui participent à
la mission ne demande pas pu aller
là-bas sanitaires certains suivent à
toulouse dans les médias français
mais ça c'est incroyable ce qu'on arrive
à faire ça dans la situation actuelle
c'est quand même c'est quand même assez
chouette est assez émouvant on a vu des
ingénieurs de la nasa plus riche que tu
choisis ma joie qui sont mis à pleurer
est spontanément que c'est énormément de
temps changent maintenant tristan qu'est
ce qui va se passer
les gens qui ont assisté à cet
atterrissage
quelles sont les prochaines étapes
immédiatement pour le rvr il va se
déplacer il va suivre un parcours alors
ils s'attendent dans les jours qui
viennent il va commencer
il a commencé par se se déployer en
quelque sorte un laïc et il est devenu
dans une dans une configuration un petit
peu replié sur lui-même
il ya notamment le mas qui vont cette
petite guerre de wall-e pour ceux qui
ont vu le film qui l'a se déplier ce
grand mas prendre des images justement
selphy pour vérifier que le mas est
correctement déployé il vend sur
commencé à se déplacer un peu pour
vérifier que tout fonctionne crois que
tu dois faire quelques mètres il va se
débarrasser d'un espèce de boucliers
qu'il a sous lui et qui protégeait
durant la descente qui va le déposer au
sol à quelques mètres
on s'en éloigne et puis donc être une
série de vérifications des instruments
qu'on attend de connaître les
instruments à bord pour que tout
fonctionne correctement et ensuite dans
les 30 premiers jours il devrait ensuite
se déplacer passé de trouver un terrain
assez propice pour déployer le petit
hélicoptère puma embarqué sous lui dans
son ventre si on veut il va déposer un
peu comme un neuf
cet hélicoptère au seul service de
petits drones avec nepal 20 m
plus d'un mètre de d'envergure qui l'a
déposé au sol ce qui va s'éloigner d'une
centaine de mètres en sécurité pour que
ce mars colmar ce cocktail essaye de
décoller et de voler dans mars la
première fois qu'un objet folle rennes
en mars
autrement qu'avec des moteurs fusées
avec le line et 10 2 fois le contrôle et
qui ma maîtresse de décoller de se
reposer c'est un petit à petit drone
quoi le corps du drone c'est un petit
cube de 10 cm avec des grandes salles
d'un mètre il faut des grandes pales
pour prendre des places sur marc parce
que l'air est très rare et fier pour
qu'ils co2 c'est un gars qui puisque
donc ça peut encore plus d'autres
problèmes voilà ça va être ça ça va être
assez chouette dans les jours à venir on
va ensuite découvrir va toutes les
images de l'atterrissage qui vont être
employés
petit à petit comme pas de reconstituer
un film de l'atterrissage il ya plein de
l'image de ses alentours de bien
meilleure qualité que c'est qu'on a pu
voir là qui vont être prises en couleurs
pouvoir ben voilà où ils se situent un
peu voilà ils ont ensuite ya ensuite il
a commencé donc à 806 fixe à tirer sur
les roches
regardez un peu ce qui l'entourent et
commentée à faire de la science
tristan j'ai fait une pause tout
simplement sur la photo de persévérance
en tous cas une des trois premières qui
ont été envoyées celle où on voit la
roue où on voit le sol martien la roue
en bas à droite c'est ce qu'on dise car
là sur cette photo on voit l que
quelques roches on ne voit pas la
couleur d'un siècle le sol martien
il est rouge orangé comment on peut le
caractériser ce sol martien qu'on voit
là sous nos yeux en quasi direct à
quelques minutes de différé de mars
quand même et comment on peut qualifier
passer un seul on dirait un petit peu un
ça va être un petit peu sablonneux c'est
un peu poussiéreux il ya quelques
cailloux donc l'horizon et de courbes
donc le
l'objectif des forts un peu d'effort un
peu l'horizon ce que je pense que
l'horizon de la doublette plutôt
horizontale
ouais est ce que tu es capable de nous
dire les types de roches qui composent
ce sol martien est ce que tu ne rentres
pas n'ont aucune idée j'ai première
question à laquelle attristant la fin la
réponse ce soir je suis pas sûr que
quiconque puisse le savoir avec
certitude il faudrait analyser pour les
oies rêve mais quelle image comme ça
c'est très délicat ça tombe bien c'est
un peu le but de ce qu'on est en train
de faire vraiment non mais c'est
chouette hein sur l'image et de super
qualité un jeu assez donné soin d'eux à
travers les cachent les images sont un
peu plus floue un peu plus brouillé la
scam de très bonne qualité chez at
kearney
le cash comprennent d un premier
panorama une première photo de ce gros
vers quoi on peut coller ressemblance
est chouette
pour adèle dans le jazz qui nous dit le
voyage sur mars pour aller sur mars
durant trente ans n'ont pas du tout à ça
dure sept mois on l'a dit tout à l'heure
ça toi qui s'ouvre tous les deux ans
tous les un peu plus de deux ans que le
26 mois c'est en fait les frais jours
avec les doigts mais en gros c on part à
un moment on est presque au plus proche
de 2 mars et on arrive à un moment où on
est un peu après avoir été au plus
proche de mars et donc ça minimise le la
trajectoire nécessaire pour aller de la
terre vers mars
et ça mais quand même voilà sept mois à
400 kilomètres je crois de distance
parcourue par l'ascendant 7 - il y en a
deux autres sont arrivés un peu plus tôt
au centre chinoise et une sonde émirati
la première mission émirati qui s'est
mise en orbite autour de mars de la
météo ouais ça hop place en europe et il
est une mission chinoise le nom j'essaie
de chanoine froide et et la saison c'est
super chouette parce que l'on classé
donc un orbiteur qui s'est mis en
on s'est mis autour de autour de mars
qu'après des belles images en arrivant
là sans doute aussi de leur arrivée ils
ont pris des photos de mars sur le blanc
leur trajet et et c'est une maison qui
va déposer aussi un rover et un
atterrisseur mais au printemps
c'est une c'est quelque chose qui
n'avait jamais été fait en corse d'avoir
se placer en orbite autour de mars et
puis ensuite de lâcher une capture ou si
vous voulez qui va se poser et c'est un
peu la même chose que pour les missions
chinoises sur la lune jeu parce que vous
allez suivre mais c'est un atterrisseur
qui a remporté au dessus un petit rover
qui va qui va rouler à la surface
quelques quelques quelques mètres j'ai
assez hâte de voir ça c'est nition assez
mignonne assez chouette est assez
emblématique serait forcément qu'un pays
se posent sur sur mars je ne sais pas si
on aura un live des opérations hausse il
faudra se contenter des informations en
différé dès le départ par l' agence
spatiale chinoise
il est 22 heures 10 heures françaises je
vous rappelle que nous venons de vivre
en direct l'atterrissage sur mars de
surfer persévérance qui était parti il y
environ 7 mois qui avait décollé on
avait déjà suivi le décollage en direct
sur figaro live on répond à vos
questions à vos commentaires ce que vous
voyez ici c'est une des toutes premières
images envoyées par persévérance elle
est en noir et blanc et je crois que
c'est mathieu dans le chat qui vous
demande quand est-ce qu'on verra des
photos en couleurs est ce qu on a une
idée tristan du délai avant d'avoir les
premières images en couleur tu me disais
qu'il y avait aussi des capacités en
couleur sur le rover mais est ce qu'on
sait quand est ce qu elles entreront en
fonction je je je danse à penser qu'on
aura des premières images en couleur dès
demain je surpris que la nasa
vous êtes même cette nuit puis à 9,7
suis je pense que demain matin il est
passionné passionnant couleurs mais j'ai
pas le jeu c'est pas le j'ai pas regardé
le détail en fait du flux de données ccc
disponibles la nasa des fois on publie
des choses comme ça où on peut les
trouver en cherchant un peu
il ya tout un déroulé prévu en fait
d'opérations de transmission de données
qui vont savoir un peu ce qui va être
tout nous il ya 25
caméra ce rollover de toutes sortes des
caméras cependant couleurs moi j'ai hâte
de ce que j'ai hâte de voir ces rondes
et les images pendant la descente où on
voit le parachute qui se déploie le sol
qui se rapproche et que tous ces images
soient combinées aussi pour faire des
petits films
ça prend pas plus de tant le temps de
reconstituer un film puisque voilà c'est
pas filmer proprement dire c'est des
images qui sont cryptés toutes les
secondes et quelques secondes donc c'est
pas exactement comme un film mais il ya
des ça sera ça prendra plus de temps il
ya des experts du traitement d'image qui
savent de quelques images comme ça une
image par seconde qui arrive à
reconstituer en fait un film en bouchant
les trous si vous voulez avec plein
d'image d'image et ça ça donne des
résultats assez incroyable ça parle
beaucoup de temps pour vous qui nous
rejoignent et sur ce live
oui pour le moment la mission est une
réussite puisque vous le voyez pas ce
que vous voyez ici c'est cet arrêt sur
image c'est une des toutes premières
photos envoyées par le rover
persévérance sur mars
on continue à prendre vos questions et
vous comment taire pendant quelques
minutes quand même on encore des
questions traitant pour toi notamment
tom d'aqui s'intéresse au climat martien
que médiatique des tempêtes sur mars est
ce qu'il y a des saisons le rover
peut-il jeu les bains gelé il doit déjà
gelé parce qu'il fait très froid mais le
roller est réchauffé par des parrains un
générateur il thermoélectriques
thermonucléaire dans ses manières
puisque aux praticiens plutonium qui se
désintègre au fur et à mesure du temps
et qui chauffe et il est petit couple
thermoélectriques qui permettent de
transformer cette chaleur en électricité
et donc du coup ce ça ça va réchauffer
le rover la température peut descendre
la séparation mars à -150 degrés celsius
pendant la nuit dans le jour il fait pas
beaucoup plus chaud il fait moins 20
degrés à 50
pour ce qui est du temps il peut y avoir
des tempêtes de poussière mais comme
l'atmosphère est un corps sans de la
terre il faut pas vous imaginer
visuellement ça peut être très
impressionnant mais ça pourrait pas
projeter un astre
notre sol comme on peut le voir le film
shoah c'est très différent
c'est quelque chose de beaucoup plus
ténu mais les tempêtes de poussières qui
peuvent être globale l'intégralité de la
planète pendant certaines certaines
parties de la saison nous ce n'est pas
en regardant ce live si vous voyez que
on passe du coq à l'âne dans les images
c'est parce que je suis en train de
naviguer en arrière dans la diffusion
fournies par la nasa pour vous retrouver
les différentes photos voilà qu'on voit
ici maintenant à l'instant de deux
persévérance qui ont été envoyées
puisque si je me positionne sur le
direct actuellement voilà la nasa est en
train de faire parler ses propres
intervenants c'est un petit peu moins
intéressant pour nous j'essaye de vous
montrer les trois images qu'on a vu tout
à l'heure voilà on voit si une je pense
qu'elles sont beaucoup plus parlante
tout en prenant vos commentaires il faut
avoir les yeux des yeux partout
tristan tite aucunement délire à quelle
vitesse sur mars pas très vite tu me
disais tout à l'heure
non elle pourra faire un pas très vite
c'est un record absolu pour faire 200
mètres par jour
après c'est pas qu'elle sait pas une
course de vitesse et un revers qui
dépasse très doucement je sais pas
combien de 20 km/heure peut-être je
comprends que ça se déplace beaucoup
plus vite un ou deux kilomètres heure
mais c'est surtout que voilà on fait
deux trois mètres on regarde mon nerf de
trois mètres et là je suis dans le but
et avec un système de navigation un
petit peu plus automatisée c'est
d'arriver à faire des plus grandes
distances dans plusieurs dizaines de
mètres tout seul automatiquement en
repérant les obstacles de manière
automatique pour éviter de les
contourner
au milieu des numéros des mots qui ont
été renforcés d'ailleurs ce que vous y
avait des roues à ses amis mais plus
vite que prévu donc truc design verrou
turover là est assez novateur
tristan à plusieurs questions que je te
soumets à la chaîne on affirmer qu'ils
nous demandent ces français ou
américains tout ce qu'on est en train de
voir qui est à la manoeuvre avait cessé
la nasa calama nord celui-ci t elle le
jet propulsion laboratory à pasadena
animé mais la france a participé à un
petit peu il ya un instrument qui la
tête du rover peut-être qu'il est de ce
petit air de wall-e qui perché sur son
mât et qui l'oeil du rover et qui est de
conception française qui était notamment
imaginé par le chercheur de l'irap à
toulouse des contributions du pinet
saint nazaire de thales alenia space
voilà c'est sait on peut on peut de fear
2 marc contribué à faire ça il
yad'autres petite contribution
européenne espagnole notamment je crois
mais voilà l'immense une immense partie
de ce rover est faite par la nasa et le
jpl
en revanche c'est le début d'une mission
de retour d'échantillons à laquelle
l'agent spatiale européenne va
activement participé pour un tiers ou un
quart donc ça va être que ça va
consister à les chercher mes
échantillons qui ont été pris par
persévérance qui ont indiqué dans des
petits tubes métalliques scellés étaient
posés au sol et donc là il ya un rover
qui allait récupérer pour être européen
une petite fusée miniature qui va les
remettre en orbite autour de mars et une
extrême votre tour de martiens un autre
vaisseau fabriqués par l'europe a priori
qui a récupéré ce petit colis cosmique
le plus cher de l'histoire pour le
ramener sur terre avec un retour prévu
2031 au plus tôt peut-être 2033
un peu plus tard voudra mais bon voilà
c'est ça l'objectif final de cette
mission le plus cher de l'histoire et tu
as répondu aussi à la question
d'astéroïdes diablo que nous demandait
at il des technologies françaises à
l'intérieur tu l'as dit oui et clément
qui nous demande puisqu'il s'agit d'une
nouvelle zone non explorée de mars
y at il des chances de découvrir de
nouvelles choses comme de nouveaux
points de vue géologique ou autres
choses de ce type tristan est ce qu'on
connaît déjà tous deux la surface de
mars
bah non pas du tout on a des gens on a
de bonnes fut une bonne couverture
depuis l'espace avec les orbiteurs on a
une très belle image globale mais mais
quand on est au sol et qu'on voit de
très près tout prend une autre saveur
une tournure on peut voir des structures
géologiques inconnu des petits oblige et
à des des objets au sens d des roches
chaudes et des petits de petites
structures géologiques étonnante
inquiète quand des falaises on va donner
d'urban et se déplacer dans des
environnements différents
après voilà après ça reste et marcin
donc en termes de couleurs en terme de
paysage la cmc désertique ces belges
orange et voilà ce niveau là on n'aura
pas de d'énormes surprises mais voilà on
aura forcément des points de vue
nouveaux des choses nouvelles
voilà ça va être très intéressant qu'il
ya toute la science parce qu'on va
analyser ce qu'on voit pas à l'oeil nu
mais ce convoi grâce aux instruments
scientifiques et c'est ça aussi ça va
être ça va être intéressant
plusieurs questions pour toi que tristan
pardon on les prend à la chaîne face de
nos bons kilos moraton des images du
drone envol j'imagine qu'ils me parler
du de la sonde dutronc louis est ce que
on aura moyen de voir un jour sa
descente alors qu'auxerre lui même sera
équipé de caméras donc il pourra prendre
des images pendant qu'il est en vol et
ensuite c'est des images qui ont été
prises de la sente pendant qu'elle le
dessin des strass pour se poser et ça on
va voir plein d'image de la descente du
parachute qui se déploie de ce qui se
rapproche peut-être le son de la
descente un microphone attaché sur la
capsule qui a enregistré le son que
produit zeller martien sur la capsule
donc sa formation qui vont arriver dans
les jours qui viennent et ça va être ça
va être super intéressant et après pour
le petit drone le rover sera une
centaine de mètres quand il décollera
je veux pas trop m'avancer mais je pense
qu'à 100 m il devrait être capable de le
voir avec certains instruments sera
peut-être pas une vidéo extrêmement
détaillées mais je pense que oui on aura
des images du petit drone démarche
kopter en voilà j'en fis qui relance le
débat de linguistes pourquoi dit on
atterrit ça ne se pose pas sur la terre
vu que c'est sur mars tristan de la 10è
l'académie française elle-même qui
recommande le terme de l'atterrissage
sur mars ou d'atterrissage sur la lune
et c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
au figaro on utilise ce terme et non pas
celui d'un bar si sage mais si vous avez
envie de dire à marcy seul dit le tout
le monde comprendra ce que ça veut dire
par contre posez vous la question s'il
faut inventer un mot à chaque fois sur
chaque planète qu'on va explorer nous
cherchons à créer voir qu'on va explorer
ça peut vite deviendra compliqué dans
les décennies voire des siècles qui
arrive
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous en tout
cas pour ce pour cela et ville et 22h20
ça fait maintenant une demi heure que
le rvr pardon persévérance est entrée
dans l'atmosphère de mars
c'est poser sur mars que vous voyez ce
sont les premières images qui nous sont
parvenues il y en a peut-être d'autres
qui sont arrivés entre temps je vais
retourner sur le direct de la nasa est
en tout cas je n'ai pas l'impression que
ce soit ce que la nasa veut nous montrer
maintenant puisque ça ce sont des images
d'archivés visiblement dose de
persévérance pardon décidément et là ce
sont différents intervenants la nasa qui
parle non pas pour ce soir dimanche on
aura beau soleil ou tristan je pense que
pour ce soir ça peut être qu'on aura
dans un premier temps ces voix là bas
quand le chat mars reconnaissance
orbiter qui est donc un des orbiteurs
essayer de prendre que c'est prendre
dans la descente
la centrale aura des images de ça mais
papa et midi lorsque nous allons pas
tarder à nous quitter pour ce soir
tristan merci beaucoup pour hâter
éclairage dix ans c'est plus de deux
heures de direct presque deux heures et
demie de direct ce soir avec vous désolé
encore toutes nos excuses pour ceux qui
sont là depuis le début avec nous pour
justement le début un petit peu
difficile de cela et notamment au niveau
du son on l'a corrigée
je ne pense que jamais ce qui est
essentiel c'est que nous avons pu vivre
ensemble en direct et dans de bonnes
conditions
l'atterrissage et les fameuses sept
minutes de terreur grâce à toi tristan
merci beaucoup on va peut-être se
quitter sur les toutes dernières
questions qu'on a notamment celle de
tristan qui nous demandent combien de
batterie et ce qu'il à se re voir
combien de temps est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre à ce qu'ils puissent tous en
vue des images à ce qu'ils puissent se
déplacer sur mars
alors il a un petit 1 un petit stock de
plutonium
à bord les intègrent progressivement
dégageant de la chaleur de manière
continue ça permet de générer 110 watts
à peu près en continu pendant combien de
temps ce une bonne question je n'ai pas
la réponse mais je vais au moins une
dizaine d'années je suis curiosity à
l'envi
12 est toujours en activité j'ai pas de
raison de penser que persévérance et
moins de batterie jeu je sais pas ce qui
va être déterrées sebala une fois qu un
peu d'énergie bling s'arrêtera s'il a
pas eu de problème mécaniques d'ici là
que ce soit mais on peut soit pas le cas
et cette question de dida cette question
de d'arrivée dame que je trouve à la
maison très intéressante attendait
chance un jour de voir des images en
direct de mars via des webcams poser sur
la planète rouge comme celles installées
dans les stations de ski
moi ça va ce pire effectivement une
question proche c'est pourquoi est ce
que on envoie des photos et pas des
vidéos en fait pourquoi est ce que les
caméras qui sont sur son rover d'en voir
les images fixes pour la même raison que
quand vous aviez internet et quelques
années avec 56 kg faisait déjà du mal an
à télécharger une image quand vous
vouliez télécharger un son de 30
secondes ou d'une minute une falaise
sées télécharger pendant deux heures et
des vidéos je prends même page
bon c'est le jeu à la bonne humeur mais
les premières vidéos qu'on télécharge
fait si vous vous rappelez mais il y
avait 40 pixels sam était 10h à ceux des
heures à se télécharger voit là et bien
là c'est pareil on peut renvoyer un
canon de données très réduit pour faire
le moindre panorama du maersk m'ont déjà
voir hyper dk hyper fin mai des
centaines d'image autres isofix envoyé
ça prend beaucoup de temps
voilà c'est une question de deux flux de
flux de données
c'est l'instant trop compliqué il n'y a
pas assez de passer devant là on peut
par oui c'est donner ça coûte trop cher
c'est trop compliqué c'est tout ça c'est
juste une question de deux flux de
données qu'il n'y a pas la fibre sur
mars
on a une internaute dans notre chatte
qui nous précise 10 ans d'autonomie
excusez-moi j'ai oublié son prénom je
n'arrive pas à le retrouver vous êtes à
ses membres dans
le chat à nous laisser vos commentaires
on à vanessa qui faisait super
commentaires en direct merci merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis durant ces
deux heures et demie de direct et gladys
qui souhaitent à une bonne soirée aux
complotistes puisque qui nous dit oui on
a reconnu la dune du pilat j'avoue
évidemment ils étaient aussi nombreux
avec tout dans cette chatte comme
d'habitude j'ai envie de dire comme sur
tous nos lives spatiaux merci beaucoup
tristan pour les éclairages je le dis à
nouveau
merci à vous dans le chat n'hésitez pas
à nous suivre et bien en vous abonnant à
7 à cette chaîne youtube on fait
régulièrement des des lives spatiaux
depuis de nombreuses années maintenant
au figaro ont notamment suivi le le
premier envoi de d'êtres humains vers
les ss en avait une capsule space x qui
les capsules crew dragonne si je me
souviens bien la triste ans c'était il
ya quelques mois de cela
aujourd'hui on est sur mars où est ce
qu'on sera demain on a terminé là dessus
tristan qu'est ce que à quoi est-ce
qu'il faut s'attendre comme grand
événement spatiaux dans les mois qui
viennent à l'écho en 2021
est-ce que tu as en tête seule voyelle
il ya thomas pesquet qui va repartir à
bord de la station spatiale
internationale en avril à bord d'une
capsule justement dragon excellente
transition sera le premier européen à
voyager avec la capture de space x
il ya comme je vous le disais le
[Musique]
l'atterrissage de la sonde chinoise qui
va nous inciter les soeurs avec un petit
rover sur marseille guingamp et et
surtout le lancement du jwst le
télescope spatial
le remplaçant de hubble si on veut qui
va nous promet des images de totalement
éblouissante qui a coûté plus de 10
milliards de dollars quatre fois le prix
persévérance qui va être lancé par une
fusée ariane 5
c'est je crois ce n'est pas encore
reporté parce que ça a été reportée
après chaque année d'un an depuis 10 ans
enfin si ça doit être la fin de l'année
en octobre me semble-t-il de mémoire
voilà pour les grands événements
auxquels je peux penser tout de suite
allez on vous souhaite une très bonne
soirée
vous pouvez continuer à suivre le
périple de persévérance évidemment aussi
sur lefigaro.fr à travers les les
articles que tristan va écrire sur la la
poursuite de cette mission et lou d'ici
là on vous souhaite une très bonne
soirée sur youtube et sur le site du
figaro à très bientôt
salut à tous merci à tous ça va
[Musique]
santé